hi i am antonia gentry and i am brian
howie
we play ginny and georgia on netflix's
junior in georgia
and we're here to do the buzzfeed quiz
to find out how well we actually
know each other
the first time we met what was that like
i mean i remember it like it was
yesterday
we read test i walked in there you were
waiting for me arms wide open you were
on the other side of the
door and then you you opened the door as
one does
and you entered the room and uh we were
all all of us expecting you
that was that was quite a life-changing
moment
okay it's my birthday september 25th
yes right yeah yeah
okay when is my birthday
mm-hmm um may
yes
come on
[Music]
that number is in it four is in it 24th
yes yes may 24th okay cool that's my
girl
okay logical sign
i am so bad at astrology is this is may
like
i'm just gonna guess here it's the most
georgia one it could actually be
taurus no aries
gemini oh i don't know i wouldn't call
it
i am the wrong one to ask leek knows
everything about astrology
well i know that you are a libra yes
you're actually the only one that got
that right everybody else got it wrong
what is my middle name venae
yes it is do you you remember mine
nicole yeah which
funny story i used to when i was in
middle school
i would convince every substitute
teacher that we had that my name was
nicole
okay what is my go-to snack on set
double stuffed oreos
yes yes it is i mean we only ate like
[Music]
can we tell the story about when when i
got double such oreos and then diesel
diesel plays austin in the show he was
so excited to also eat double stuffed
oreos he got so excited he was so full
of like
just food that he threw up
in the middle of the mayor's office yeah
he was bouncing around one moment
and then just like
it was so great i mean he was fine he
was fine you know we were concerned
but he was fine your go-to snack you
really liked
the well i know you like goldfish yeah
but you also like um tuna melts
oh my gosh i love tuna so much yes i
love
tuna and crackers coffee order
yeah this one's kind of a trick question
for me you like
oh shoot why
well drink coffee oh we could do
pancakes
yes yes exactly it does i'm not here's
the first things we talked about
right i'm not supposed to drink coffee i
do sometimes because like i need it you
know
but it gives me migraines so i had to
avoid it on set
that's good that was great um i don't
know your coffee order though
i'm just gonna guess i'm gonna just like
are you a latte woman or a cappuccino
woman neither
do you even like coffee i love coffee
wait what okay
white chocolate mocha no oh my god
it's i like coffee with my creamer
i just want like a lot of creamer and
then straight coffee
your first acting job
well i don't know was it because i the
first thing i saw you in was exorcist
but i know that wasn't your first
rodeo my first my first professional was
90210
really what was that like were you like
a wow
i was a girl this is ridiculous i was a
girl
bidding on one of the main characters
for an auction and i think my line was
three hundred dollars
and i just had to keep yelling three
hundred dollars over and over
again i have to find that episode
you don't i feel like yours is what anya
mentioned last night
but i can't remember what it's called
was that your oh
no that actually wasn't my first one
that was my second one
then is it candy jars yes yes good dog
okay what was your favorite scene there
are so many scenes
i know you really like the scene after
um
and episode seven after like jenny has
her night in jail
and after the big secret reveal and you
know we have that nice tender moment
the morning after eating donuts i don't
know
but you really like that one that one
for sure i mean most of my scenes with
you
because georgia gets to let her guard
down and be
as close to the realest version of
herself as possible
yeah i agree what is your favorite scene
it's like the one where i'm like ooh and
then you're like
i'm gonna do it without like doing it
you know where we're like fighting in
your bedroom
in your bedroom
that one yeah like then he finds out
some stuff then george is like
yes and he's like what are you doing
i know i don't know how to i know i
can't how do we do that without giving
it away that's a good thing one
is a good scene yeah that was fun what
is my favorite movie or tv show
i know yours i mean at least i know what
tv show you really love
so many because well yeah like he's
yours
richardson no although i love bridgerton
what is yours um my well my favorite
movie
is pan's labyrinth i would not have
guessed that okay
and my favorite tv show is
probably okay well now it's queen's
gambit
but before that it was um breaking bad
yeah but so i don't know what your
favorite movie is
but i feel like i know a show that you
always talk about
is like like the real housewives are
like
oh yeah i love all of them i like every
single
one bravo yeah those are my friends yeah
so what's your favorite movie then i
mean
i always spell
really that's my boyfriend's favorite
movie
really ezra's favorite movie oh ezra i
love that guy
oh my god who are our biggest celebrity
crushes
my biggest celebrity crush is actually
pretty easy it's like
it's something obvious it's very obvious
it's like
un-original oh robert pattinson yes it
is
yeah like every
young woman my age like i'm just um
okay your biggest celebrity crush is it
someone from friday night lights
yeah coach coach taylor
taylor what's his name kyle chandler
kyle chandler god that's right he has
two first names
and i had worked with scott before which
was really fun on heart of pixie
scott's really awesome but he's no kyle
chandler apparently
according to brianne he's the coach
and he gives those inspiring speeches
he's really there for these young boys
right i checked out seven out of ten
i don't want to get myself too many ah
you won
that makes sense i love this you've been
in each other's lives for quite some
time now
and you got very close while filming
you're basically the same person oh
i guess i'll improve my score as soon as
i watch real housewives
exactly that is the moral of the story
thank you
you